good morning so um
we're here to talk about uh the book
that y'all panrot and i did together
my name is hudson and i wrote this book
about a friend of mine
i was really surprised to hear one day
i had the radio on i had been working in
my studio i was about to leave for new
york city
and there's an interview show on
a local radio station from albany new
york
and the interviewer says and today
ladies and gentlemen we have our very
own
schindler of from our region on mr yacht
penrod
like oh yeah what are you doing on the
radio schindler as you know was a great
hero of the holocaust a holocaust
rescuer
and so i think what is yap my friend my
buddy for 12 years doing on the radio
and i start listening
and i hear this story about how
when he was a young man in amsterdam had
rescued over
400 people from the nazi holocaust
the radio station had gotten word that
he was receiving an award from
an israeli organization called yad
vashem
who honors among other things non-jewish
people who helped to save the lives or
rescue jewish people during
the time of the holocaust
so that's how they knew about it i
started listening i called my friends
and said everybody turn on your radio
yaps on the radio and
it was a fascinating story that i heard
about how he figured out this little
scheme
to get his jewish friends out of
amsterdam out of harm's way
and on their path to freedom what he did
was more or less set up
something of an underground railroad i'm
sure you all are familiar with
the story of harriet tubman and the
underground railroad for
getting slaves out of the south before
the civil war here in this country
yap did more or less the same thing to
help get jews out of
holland so i was telling friends about
it over dinner that night
and they said well you got to write a
book about it and i thought well you
know
i'd like to but it just doesn't you know
it's so different from anything else
i've
ever um written before i've written
stories about
dinosaurs coming to new york and uh
king arthur and the knights of the round
table but it just seemed so far afield
from
anything i had ever done before it was
far too
serious and real and um
it just it didn't feel like you know i
was born after the war it didn't feel
like
my history but i realized that as long
as i was thinking it's not
my story it's not my history
it wasn't that different than what
people at the time were saying
which was it's not my problem it's their
problem
and i realized that was something that
yap was not saying
yap isn't jewish but he felt like
he just couldn't stand by and
see what was going on to the jewish
people his jewish friends
and even the people he didn't know he it
was
an injustice that he was not going to
participate in he felt like he had to do
something about it
the main thing that i've i realized in
studying the
the situation there in amsterdam at the
beginning of the war was that
the nazis were very good at making you
feel helpless
they made everybody feel like a bunch of
scare rabbits
kind of in that way they could sort of
keep everybody under control
you know if you feel powerless then
you're just going to do what the person
in command tells you to do
and they were very good at that they
they really did their job very well
yap didn't buy into that he sort of felt
like you know
there must be something i could do and
i'll figure out
how to do it and so for me i realized
yap did what he could at the time and it
sort of inspired me to feel like well
then i should do what i could
and that's to write a book about his
story and share it with all of you
because
as time moves on more and more people
who actually witnessed it and
experienced the holocaust and
lived through it are gone now they're
they're disappearing
every day very quickly and
we need to get their stories while we
still can
otherwise we're all left to
the discretion of whoever would rewrite
history in their favor
and there are many out there who would
so it's good that we all know
now what really happened what really
went on from those who lived it
who went through it who can still share
it with us while they're still here
so that's what inspired me to do this
book
the story goes like this
when you off i'll i'll start if you
don't mind i'll just i'll tell
yop's story and then he can take over at
a certain point
um the nazis came into power
um you know in the early 30s in germany
by 1940 they were taking over europe
the blitzkrieg happened
they took over the blitzkrieg means
lightning war they were
flying over one country after another
marching into it and taking it within a
few days so holland fell within eight
days
and um shortly uh after the nazis were
were there they started issuing id cards
to everyone
and everybody had to carry them
identification cards
jewish id cards look like this same
thing with a picture on it except that
there was a big black j
stamped on the back of it so obviously
they were already starting to
separate the jewish dutch citizens out
from everyone else
so yap and his friends thought well
let's try just um
you know bleaching out the j that didn't
work
um because it left a big white
blotch on it on the on the id card
so he thought well you know why don't i
just try my hand
at uh forging one
now this was that was a smart thing to
do because y'all
had access to printers inks his father
was a printer
he printed books and so
he also had experience at drafting
because he was
an architecture student so he was very
skilled with his hand at
you know making nice clean lines and
good lettering
at the same time his friend crean to
conus was a good photographer so
they got in the business of making fake
id cards
now this was important you see because
at the time
um if you were carrying an id card with
a big black j on the back of it
a nazi could stop you on the street and
card you and see the j and
haul you in right there on the spot and
people wouldn't see you again that
happened
that happened with some frequency so
this was
you know a step toward trying to shelter
people as long as they could
anyway it worked they started making
uh false papers to for their jewish
friends
with new uh ids new names that didn't
sound like jewish names you know sort of
christianized names
new photographs and for
a good year and a half it was it was
very effective
unfortunately the nazis kept moving in
tighter and tighter
around the jewish community isolating
them from the rest of the dutch
population
pretty soon they put up barbed wire all
around
a jewish part of town making it into the
jewish ghetto
basically and
forcing all jews from all over holland
to uh to move into there
uh cramming everybody into this one tiny
little part of town
and then by april of 42 um everyone was
forced to wear the yellow star
which i'm sure you've seen pictures of
uh
around that time is when they started um
taking people away to germany on train
loads and nobody at that point
really knew where they were going but
they had you know
a pretty bad suspicions um there had
been
work camps concentration camps uh
set up as soon as the nazis came to
power in germany
um you know where people were
essentially just worked to death
and so they thought that that was a
possibility of where people were going
but of course the nazis weren't saying
anything
in any case there was a big scramble for
hiding places
i'm sure you know the story of anne
frank and her family
people were looking just to hide
wherever they could
but hiding is a big logistical problem
you see
for say like a non-jewish dutch citizen
to take on the responsibility of hiding
somebody
it means that you've got to take care of
their food and
water and so forth into the foreseeable
future
if they had any medical problems or
whatever you had to be the one to be the
go-between
and they had to be totally still during
the day because you couldn't trust
the neighbors to make you know if there
was any noise or anything like that
you didn't know who to trust you didn't
know anything
so there were so many problems with
hiding people besides the fact that
amsterdam is a small town there's not
that many hiding places
and um
also holland is a very flat country so
it's easy for people to be seen you know
trying to cross the countryside
now a lot of people did go into hiding
on the farms that was a
most a more typical place to hide people
away from the big metropolitan areas
but yap was a city boy he didn't know
that many people on farms
so his idea was to just try to get
people
out of danger out of harm's way
and he came up with this this plan that
i
i thought i would read you um it's from
this chapter here called a new plan now
it starts when he's recovering from
having spent two months in prison the
nazis did bring him in under suspicion
of helping
um his jewish countrymen
they they put him in the bureau of
jewish affairs and questioned him
somebody had
given him given them his his name
uh under suspicion that he was making id
cards
they questioned him they put him in
solitary confinement they put him in a
a tiny little cell with four people and
fed him
uh you know like a piece of bread and uh
you know a bowl of water for
a few months but ultimately they didn't
really have anything on him and
let him go now they may have let him go
because they didn't have anything on
them but also
the nazis were very whimsical you never
really knew what they were going to do
and every now and then they would let
somebody go just to kind of throw
everybody off balance
in any case yup by some great
good fortune did get out and um
uh he was here in this at the beginning
of this chapter he's recovering of
course from malnutrition if you're on
bread and water for two months you're
going to be suffering from malnutrition
and he's in bed when his friend crane is
coming
over to tell him what's been going on so
this is a chapter called a new plan
and it's autumn of 1942 and it starts
this way
yup it's gotten worse since you've been
gone supreme
i didn't think that was possible yap
replied from his bed he was still
recovering from prison
it feels like a sinking ship cream
continued
everybody's trying to cling to the end
of the boat that's still sticking out of
the water but it's going down fast
the nazis are taking everybody now five
thousand in one night last week
five thousand in one night it was awful
yap they were going house to house in my
parents neighborhood
we were out in the street now pajamas
but there was nothing any of us could do
my dad tried to stop them from taking
our neighbor mr meltzer
but he just got the butt of a rifle in
his face
my mother put her coat around an old
lady but they just yanked it off
they even emptied out the jewish nursing
home down at the end of the street
what could they do with a bunch of old
people it was total madness
green peered out the window a jewish
family was
being loaded into a truck while the
nazis lit cigarettes and laughed
he just shook his head and turned away
we can't hide a hundred thousand people
we're lucky if we can even hide
ourselves
but what are we supposed to do just
stand here and watch it happen
i've been working on a new idea yap said
i heard about an underground group
working with the allies
they rescued down british and american
pilots and bring them to france
the french underground takes them across
the pyrenees to spain
and then the spanish get them down to
gibraltar where they pick up a boat for
england
maybe we could set up our own line to
get jews out of here
how inquired cream with false paper said
yap just like the ones we've been making
just a different kind i think i can get
my hands on documents from a german
construction company
i'll copy their letterhead and print it
on blank paper so it looks very official
but then i'll write a letter on it
saying that the company has hired
us to bring workers to their job site in
france
then we use the letter to apply for an
official travel permit
and this job site would be the atlantic
wall said yup
the germans are building this huge wall
all along the coast of europe now all
the way
down from norway to spain i know about
it said
crean but is this company building it
who knows i don't even know if they
exist anymore said yup
it's just a chance we'll have to take
but the nazis have over 500 000 people
working on the wall right now
they want to make europe into a gigantic
fortress there's no way that they can
keep track of who's doing what and where
crean stood up he paced back and forth
and stopped suddenly
why don't you just forge a travel permit
i don't have a real one to copy said yap
fake papers only work if they're
identical to the real ones
if it's wrong we're dead hmm
that's a problem said cream the
important permits are issued only in
paris
now yap was out of bed also pacing back
and forth
so since we don't have a travel permit
yet
we'll have to sneak to paris to get one
right
i think so said crane but one more thing
it also depends on having a good
connection at the other end who do we
know in paris
jean-paul he moved back at the beginning
of the war said yeah
oh of course he'll have contacts in the
french underground
i better get dressed said yap we have
work to do
the next day yacht visited an architect
friend who had worked with the german
construction company
he gave yap a few papers printed with
the company logo
that night yap sat to work transferring
the logo to blank paper using a small
press and printers inks in his father's
print shop
the letter had to be written in perfect
german so they asked the help of a
german friend who had fled naz the nazi
regime
regime with the false signature of the
company director
the document was complete yacht blew on
the
on it to dry the ink and then laid it
down in the center of the table
they stared at it for a long moment and
then looked at each other
well there's step one said yacht
now for step two right answered queen
paris so i'll move on to the next
chapter which is they're
working their way to paris
yap and queen were silent all the way to
maastricht
there were just a few nazis on board the
little train they were now taking to the
south end of holland
but they were thinking about the next
one since traveling to paris without
papers meant risking their lives in any
case
they decided that their best chance
would be to hide in plain sight
riding among the germans themselves
a german troop train would have no
conductors tickets or border checks
there was one heading to france that
made a stop in my strict at midnight
they planned to board it and do their
best to blend into the crowd
the blue gray dusk of the wintery
afternoon had already settled over the
medieval town when they stepped off the
train
nightfall in my strict like all of
europe was unbroken by a single light
that could attract the allied bombers
the two young men wandered the kabul
streets until curfew time
8 pm they took refuge in the men's room
at the train station
and waited shortly after midnight a
whistle pierced the stillness
with the screech of breaks the station
suddenly filled with german clatter
yap and crane quickly adopted the frank
mood and pushed their way up the steps
of the train
the car they entered was packed with a
full array of the german military
as the train lurched forward yap and
queen swayed with the masses of nazis
pressing against them
luftwaffe ss gestapo security police
and every rank of the vermont were all
in the mix of uniforms
but there were also many in plate and
clothes giving the cover for yap and
queen's own lack of uniforms
during the night the train slowed and
stopped repeatedly as soldiers ran out
and checked for bombs hidden under the
tracks
how ironic yap thought our biggest
danger right now is from our own boys in
the belgian underground
nine hours later yap and queen emerged
at the station
in leo in northern france they found
their way to a bus heading for paris and
within hours they were standing in
jean-paul's apartment
hazing out at the eiffel tower while he
prepared dinner for them
they were awake before dawn the next
morning the day
had arrived when they would walk into
the lion's den
the nazi head office called the proof
stella
whether they walked out again with or
without the papers rested entirely on
something that old mr mandelbaum called
hutzbach
his word for guts the proof stella was
on the champs-elysees the main street of
paris
it was the central clearing office for
all permits and licenses in western
europe under the third reich
they decided to wait till noon before
entering the proof stella
fewer people would be around and those
who were might be more focused on lunch
than on their own jobs
if someone called the director of the
construction company in germany
to verify yap and queen's letter perhaps
he would be at lunch too
they knew there were a thousand things
that could go wrong
all they could do was try and minimize
them and hope for the best
yelp and queen entered the vast marvel
hall
it was crowded with officials and
military personnel
they found the shortest line good day
miss
yap said to the young uniformed woman
behind the counter
i think you'll find our papers in order
we're here to obtain a one moment please
she said with her head down looking at
their letter
she filled out a form and paper clipped
it to the letter then set it aside
your travel papers please but
that's what we're here requesting yop
said evenly ours as well as the group of
workers will be leading
the woman looked at him for a long
moment
yes of course she finally said
return to this window between three and
four p.m
will you still be here s job she nodded
yap and queen tipped their hats and
walked away
they both breathed deeply when they were
outside again
so now they've got to go back there
and see if they're going to give them
their papers
or if something else will be waiting for
them so i think at this point i'll turn
it over to the man himself
and let him continue the story okay
we decided that it would be better if we
went
one after another not the two together
because
the danger is greater for two not for
one
when it was my turn i went into that
hall again
i never saw the same woman again who
helped us in the morning
but so i went to one of these lines
i told them told her what i was doing
maya was there
she went into the back came back with a
a courier paper a courier permit
courier shine in german and which was a
long paper
folded many times with all the
information on it
which entitled me to bring
workers to bring people from one point
in europe to another point
in other words i could use it to bring
people from holland
to france
this and with it
they gave us a whole stack of
copies of permits actually
they were not permits they would they
were
papers which the workers needed to fill
out their name their address how old
they were
where they lived and then which is the
same as an entrance
sort of like blank forms blank blank
forms
and entitling them to
food coupons
and that was very important because
we took these things back to holland as
quickly as
possible
these papers were needed of course to
give each
of the jewish kids who we brought to
france
a new identification we gave them new
names
and that is something which you will
understand how
how difficult it is if you go for 16 or
70 years
by the name of isaac mondelbaum
and all of a sudden you become hank
roten house
that that is not only very
difficult but it is you have to be on
your tv
all the time because the germans had all
these little tricks
they when they saw people together they
would shout hey
isaac come here and if the real isaac
would happen to be so unfortunate to
stand up
they would catch you of course
this never happened because not because
we
indoctrinated them well enough but they
were
they were fighting for their life and
in those cases you are very
careful and and uh on your toes
now we filled out these papers
for about i must say that they were very
crude papers because
in those days they didn't have xerox
machines
to make copies they had a system called
mimeography you you made a master
on a kind of gelatin paper
and then in in a drum you would rotate
it and
out came kind of crude copies
but that was exactly what we wanted
because
that looked real of course so it was
easy for us to copy
the papers which they gave us because we
needed hundreds of them
the power of these papers came from the
fact that there were stamps on it
a german stamp was a circle
which i made by the way i had an old egg
cup
which was the exact size of the real
circle so i use the egg cup
looks like this yeah right
here's the yeah there's the stamp
there's the stamp
and the uh around within the circle
it would show the the the the people who
had
issued the the permit
depending upon what it was it was always
a different name
i and a different town who issued the
permits
and and then in the middle there was
this german
eagle and in the middle of the german
eagle it has the
head of swastika and the germans had so
many papers
they didn't know whether they were
coming or going they didn't know
what was real and unreal if you showed
them a paper with the
stamps on it they believed it to be true
we assembled about 20 people i
i really don't know whether they were 19
or 20
i forget but these were friends
of friends they were
if they were young enough they were our
our friends
or us sometimes they were the children
of friends
and we issued them the proper names and
papers
and now we were off to our first convoy
our first trip
to lille and we we were
very very lucky it went without a hitch
no no problem at all
when we got to lille not the first time
but on one of these
trips i remember we were
very late arriving because these trains
took a long time at a trip which usually
took
eight hours or so could take 24 hours
or even longer because
besides the locomotive behind the
locomotive
they were steamed locomotives of course
they had a flat car with cannons on it
and
german soldiers and in the back of the
train the same thing
and when the british would come over
and shoot at the train those cannons
would shoot back at the planes
and believe me that's not a happy
situation to be in
you're always maybe you all i've seen
this
illustration this was a fun thing for me
to
to do if you can see the the german guns
are down here on this flatbed car
and hear the british spitfires flying
over strafing the plane
often we had to leave the train and the
train stopped of course and then we had
to leave and lay in the field in a ditch
or so
until it was safe again and then we went
further
in in addition there was the there were
the
uh resistance workers in belgium or in
france
trying to blow up the trains and blow up
the rails
they didn't know that we were aboard
they they thought they were
trying to sabotage a german train
and we did that
about 20 times
not about exactly 20 times
uh at one point in amsterdam
we entered the compartment where we were
supposed to be seated
you know in the european trains are a
little different they have
a long corridor and compartments
on one side and as we entered
that one compartment where i was
supposed to be seated with
six others the um
there were german officers there and
they said they didn't want us
so i went to find the leader of the
train there was always
the germans always had a leader for
everything so
a train too had a leader i found him
and i told him the story that we are not
wanted there
but this is very important that we bring
these laborers to the atlantic wall
we are helping you winning the war and
he agreed to that he thought it was a
good argument
he went back threw the germans out
and now all of a sudden the jews were
being seated
in a compartment and the
the germans were thrown out i think that
was the first time this this
must have happened the jews were being
seated
instead of germans
this came to a halt because
in april of 1944
it was about five weeks before the
uh invasion of normandy when the allied
armies
invaded normandy they had bombarded the
northern france
completely there were no trains anymore
there were no stations there there was
no rails there was nothing it was all
gone
so that is why we stopped
doing it and all in all we had brought
406 people according to
black yap who was the man who helped me
finding the jews because i only knew so
many
i only knew the people in the beginning
friends and friends of friends
but i ran out of people and but he he
knew how to
how to find them and bring them to us
his name was black young because i was
blown yap
and that's all we knew of each other you
never knew
who someone you worked with boss you
didn't know his background
not only didn't you know you didn't want
to know it because
you by by giving
the improper information to someone you
might not
endange not only endanger the situation
he might endanger his life too because
if you know more
then you should burden him with
information which
he shouldn't have
after that when being in holland i went
into hiding myself
because now they were not after the jews
anymore they were after
any male between 16
and 65 was caught whenever they could
lay
their hands on you for slave labor in
germany
so i went into hiding in a small village
with a doctor friend who had a barn next
to his house
and that's where we survived the war
after the war many of these people who
had joined
the allied armies came back to holland
when they were stationed in germany as
an occupation army
and they it was nice to meet them that
we've all made it through the war
i think that's the gist of my story well
it's good
and he ended up getting out
at least 406 people that
that we know about that's been
documented through
yad vashem the the people who uh awarded
him the medal for the righteous among
nations
um and you've been living in the united
states since 1958 right
that's correct yeah so now we have some
time for questions
i will be the first yes sir
um what was the closest that you've ever
come
to being caught by the nazis uh what was
the
did you hear the question yeah yeah well
it's it's hard to think about which day
was more
frightful than another but i i do know a
situation
where we were in a little town
where the train stopped and that little
in the middle of holland
and that train was so long and the
station was so
small that the
only a certain amount of wagons
could stand in the station next to the
platform
and all the rest was out in the field
i've seen it here happening too in in
little towns
here
the germans had a trick then
they would this was in the middle of the
winter
and it was very very not only cold it
was a terrible winter it was snowing and
hailing and very very bad weather they
had us go
out of the train and they had us
drop our pants now why would they do
that
in europe used or circumcised
non-jews were not so that was
an item identification which they could
miss
and as we were doing that
it took it took some time and and
i forget the details but at one point
they said okay back in the cars they i
think they wanted
they didn't want to get wet either the
the policeman
and i think that was the closest we
would get
to disaster because had they found out
that they were jews they would have shot
us
right there on the spot they they didn't
do any they didn't give you a
fine or they didn't take you to prison
they just shot you
yes did you ever
encounter any of the people you you
helped
bring to freedom yes after the war yeah
many came back uh off as a as i said
earlier who were civilians couldn't
travel right after the war
but the ones who were in the armies they
they
in uniform they they could travel they
had
jeeps and they they were stationed in
germany then and they came to
holland their their their
country of origin when they had a
day off for a couple of days off and
i saw many of them i saw
but then after i after we left for
america in 58 it petered out
i i don't think that people could could
find me
because you you don't leave an address
at least 50 addresses since
one man i know came to new york to see
me
and he was not a man whom we had brought
to france
he was the son of a man who we had
brought to france
and that was nice
yes kelly um um
when they burned books in the beginning
do you think they like burned books
because
they were afraid that people would get
like knowledge and
then they would they could get they'd
know and then they could
like do something to damage their way of
having them like go on yeah that's
that's a great question
uh callie's asking uh when they burned
books at the beginning
in when the nazis first came into power
in in germany
um what do you think their motive was
why why were they burning books were
they afraid of
like the ideas that are were in the
books or
or were they afraid that they would
challenge their
authority yeah basically why were they
burning books
well because they the first thing
dictators always fear are the
intellectuals
are the people who think are the writers
and of course behind each book is a
writer
they fear that mostly because
in books you can find ids which are very
different
from the dictator's
id and so anyone who
who was against hitler and the third
reich the third
the right yeah that's right anyone who
was against it was an enemy of the state
and especially if they had jewish names
they they would i mean
whatever it was in their
eyes the enemy they would burn the books
but then again so many and
they they didn't allow
certain music because they
it was written by jews now it is
it's crazy to think about it but this is
what happened
it's very unreal these things
certainly they didn't want people to
think for themselves
that was the first thing that they
wanted to stop they wanted to make sure
that
everybody was torn the line at
the same kind of thought of this
same support for the system that they
had so everybody was all
collectively you know into one
frame of mind that's the way they can
control people
when you think for yourself it's scary
to the authorities
so that's why i encourage it highly
folks anyway who's next
yes um i was wondering why you came to
america
after the war that happened in 56
you might i you might not even have been
born
you were not born then but in hungary
you know the the the country in the the
balkan
next to austria they had
the russians had occupied it and
in 1956 there was a revolt
the people stood up against the russians
and the russians smashed that revolt
with the tanks in the streets and they
shot thousands of people
and we my wife and i really thought
it's gonna start all over again
so we wanted to leave europe
it didn't start all over again but that
we didn't know then
i applied for american citizenship and
american immigration papers which was
very difficult to get
them because
all these countries had quota they only
allowed so many
belgium so many italians so many
spaniards
so many englishmen into this country
here
and the quota for the dutch was already
filled for years and years to come
so but again i was lucky
i knew the president of the american
institute of architects and he knew me
and my work
and he wrote letters in my behalf
that i would be we would be an asset
to the america and we became non-voter
immigrants
that they allowed if if if the americans
thought that you you could help them
here that
that they allowed let's see how about
you
do you know if there are remains of the
atlantic wall still standing
there are there are as a matter of fact
i saw a uh
on one of these shows recently
i saw a discovery channel or
one of the they had they have a segment
called
the atlantic wall and
they they showed how it was built
they recognized me in that in that show
too
because they've inserted it since then
that
i use the atlantic wall as a pretext to
get people
out of holland they
try to blow up most of it but
certain things are too close to
communities that too big that they just
let them
rot away they will be there for the next
20 000 years i guess see
the germans not only build new
fort fortresses but sometimes
when there were the hotels
of villas situated next to the
to the shoreline they used the the the
house
as a mold they just poured concrete in
it
and so it was it still looks like a
house but it was a bunch of concrete
with
cannons sticking out
um next uh yes how about you
um would you ever consider going back to
your original home
to my old home yes
my wife and i used to go back once or
twice a year
but lately my wife is not
she's became an invalid and it's hard
for her to travel
so in the past three and a half years i
haven't been
back but the houses are still there
still it still looks like amsterdam i
was just there last week
uh let's see how about you did anyone
ever like betray you
or something that's a good question well
that's why i was arrested a man
actually he was an ice cream vendor at
the corner of the street
we always bought ice cream from him and
he was arrested
and but what they always liked to know
the germans
was with whom did you work who who are
you
helpers and he he told them
that he had given me identification
papers
real ones which we then changed
which was true the only thing was he
he shouldn't have done it but i don't
know what what methods
they used to get that information out of
him that's why they arrested me
but i i
so that that was a kind of betrayal but
you you can
never really uh
you can never really tell people that
is a bad thing considering the methods
they used
to get that information out of you
if you were they might
be beyond torture which they did too
they might have as i said you you have
an hour to tell us what we want to know
or else we're going to kill your wife or
we're going to kill your kids
i mean so you you cannot blame anyone
for what we now call betrayals
well let's see how about you um
what did you think was the scariest part
of
your whole journey in
saving the jews well as i explained
a minute ago that that night in the
middle of the winter
i think that was the the closest we got
by
by being alive well certainly probably
when you were being shot at from the
by the brits too i imagine would have
been a pretty scary
yeah but that that is kind of i mean
that
when we leave now we might get into a
car accident
these things you take for granted right
that's part of life but uh
let's see who have i not called on how
about you in the back there yes
um were the jews always killed when you
when they got caught did they ever just
throw them in a
did they lock them up or they always
just kill them that's what they did in
the
in the beginning they uh
see the germans had a very vicious game
they they
they let what they called the jewish
council they let the jews decide
which jew had to be sent to a camp
or finally to auschwitz so
so it was not them it was the jews
themselves who did it
which was of course a terrible thing
and the people who were part of that
jewish council
they were trying to
be safe themselves
i mean they rather let someone else go
the germans only had to say next monday
we need 1200
youth and they were then sent to
a camp in holland
from which the trains would depart i
forget every tuesday night i believe
to our feet
you know you must have seen pictures of
these these
freight trains uh barbed wire around it
and uh a lot of people never made it
because if you're stuck
in a in a cattle wagon
without food or drink for
three days and two nights a lot of
people die
already on the way old people don't make
it
and very small ones don't make it either
and they took of course
everyone they took them from whether
women were pregnant or had a baby of two
weeks
or whether a jew was
98 years old they couldn't care less
they they wanted to
to take the jews out of this world
and they succeeded quite well in that
after all six million people who killed
6 million jews and 6 million is an
awful lot of people i mean you know what
i always
wondered about when i was your age was
how is it possible how could they
get away with killing six million people
and in doing the research for this book
and kind of understanding
the nazi's methodology i realized that
they were very good at what they did
um they used deception a lot and
betrayal basically saying one thing and
getting people
to kind of go along with them basically
saying you know
if you just do this nobody will get hurt
or
maybe we'll take them but we won't take
you so they played it was a
psychological game they played on
people's uh kind of tendency to
just kind of want to go along with what
they're told to do
play it safe don't rock the boat don't
question authority
um that you know they first made
everybody feel
weak and helpless and then said if you
just go along with us
we'll do that and that way they could
just very quietly
funnel everybody toward this final end
that
so many of them unfortunately met um
that's what's so amazing that that was
the whole
environment everybody was in that frame
of mind
and that's what's kind of remarkable
that there were people like yap who just
refused to go along with it and as you
always say you were not the only one
there was
many great people in the dutch
underground who were doing what they
could
but still it's kind of amazing to think
of what it's like
to have to take that on yourself to
think for yourself
without um the government telling you
what's the right thing to do uh your
community nobody else around you
kind of uh supporting you you really
having to act on yourself your own
sense of morality from within and your
own guts your own instinct to do
actually something about it
not an easy place it was always of
course
not only the germans who took the jews
away
because you have to realize that of all
these
millions of people they lived in houses
and all these houses all of a sudden
became empty
and were taken over by the neighbors so
there was a
as it was quite an incentive for people
to say
to go to the germans to say there are
jews living next door
and they were rounded up and taken away
because they wanted that house
so there was always a lot of betrayal
going on
beyond what the nazis did that
yes did anybody bring to paris
betray you or run away no
we were very very lucky with that it as
i said
it sometimes was difficult sometimes we
we were afraid but
that something would happen but it never
happened no one ever betrayed us
we took all kind of precautions
but you can only do so much yay
you you never know what will happen the
next moment
it's amazing that none of the boys they
were all just boys too they were all
just like teenagers
16 17 year old none of them
messed up their story whenever and they
had to cross lines they were questioned
you know when people came around to
see their their papers they all stuck
with their story and knew exactly what
to say and how to
conduct themselves so there was actually
a lot of heroes to
when you think about it all the people
who managed to get out and go along with
the whole
plot were also quite heroic in their own
way yeah
how about you oh
go ahead do you have a question
yeah how come you couldn't just go into
a store and
buy what you needed like you couldn't
just go into a grocery store
and buy the food you needed
well first of all the government decided
the government gave us cards coupons on
it
and in the newspaper which was by the
way the only
these were the german-controlled there
was only one
and there was no radio there was no
television
so the newspaper was the only thing
which
had government information
and that would say as of next monday
on coupon number 69 you can get
half a pound of flour
so with that you went to the store and
you gave her the coupon and you got
you were allowed to buy half a pound of
flour
so everything the stores were empty
you could you couldn't walk by
shelves that there was nothing only when
you came with the coupons
would they give you what you were
entitled to
which at the end of the war was so
so little we got
a kilogram and a half which is about
three pounds
american pounds of a sugar beet
which is a big beet
which is usually given to to
cattle as cattle father
with that we got i forget the amount
a few potatoes and a piece of bread
about
this long for a week
a person so it's not to
in amsterdam alone 2 000 people died
every week and they couldn't even be
buried because
no one could could could afford
to to spend energy on burying other
people so they were lying in the streets
and
rotted away you it's it's hard to
when i think back it it's it's hard to
imagine that
the situation of these times it's
in in holland it's still known as the
hunger winter
when people were starving to death it
was after
the allies had landed in d-day and they
were making their way toward germany
but they got stopped at uh at a big
river
and the germans had dug in and so the
southern part of holland was liberated
but the northern part
was um still behind enemy lines
and the germans had taken everything
every scrap of food even the topsoil as
yap said every single thing
and um so the the people of holland were
starving to death they were eating tulip
bulbs anything they could to
possibly keep alive so we we really
don't know what it's like
to have those kind of conditions in this
country we've
we've been so lucky that we've been
spared that so far so
it's always a point that i like to make
that we really appreciate what we have
here and what our
our freedom has given us now you had a
question this young man right here in
purple
um after the world war ii were you
involved in any other wars or movements
no no i was involved
in the rehabilitating of a
a french village as an architect
i rebuilt a few farmhouses there
but i was never involved in any illegal
situation uh let's you have not called
on yet yes sir how about you
how ol how old were you when you uh
started
bringing jews to uh england
i was born in 1918 so
i was 21 and 22 years of age
um in the book um in the book on page
39 i think um there's the ark
and you drew it so it has two red flags
on it and
then the ark and then there's like a
little black part right over the ark
did you draw that so it kind of looks
like hitler yeah you noticed
yeah if you if you can see that on
camera
um do you know what arc that is anybody
can tell her yeah
arc of triumph right exactly the arctic
tree office it's called in french
it's right in the center of paris uh the
arctic triomphe is to the french people
sort of like the way the statue of
liberty
is to us it's sort of their symbol of
nationality of who they are as a people
and so for the germans to come in and
put
nazi flags on it is basically saying we
own you now
we're on top of you so that's
essentially what i was showing
but you caught what i was doing
underneath with the image
i wanted to make look make it look more
or less like
hitler's face there suddenly you know
just
so that some people saw it um anyway
wrapping up here what else uh would
would you like to say
you always have a last few words and so
do i
well the the the poem line the poem or
about being a bystander yeah
that is one thing i would really like
you to
to know and and act don't
be bystanders this this will not happen
again but
similar things will happen
things which make you being part
of a bad situation and you can shrug it
off and walk away from it i said well it
doesn't concern
me but it should concern you and you
should try to do whatever you can
to change it you use in this country
you know the minorities if
you sit sitting in a school bus you
certain of your friends might gang up
to another kid just because his
color of his skin is different or
because he is
because you were told he is gay and that
you don't want
or they don't want or he
is is a latin and you say well what
why the hell are they coming here as if
your forebears didn't come here under
the same circumstances
you should do do something about all
these things
you don't have to be a great hero to to
help minorities or to help people
in danger
yeah and i would like to say myself just
building on that
what i've really gotten out of doing
this book and what i'd like to share
with all of you about it is to really
show how
one person can make a difference how
each one of us
has the possibility to do something
heroic we all have the possibility of
heroism
in us even in a small way uh within our
lives there we all have that possibility
just as the
example of yap uh showed us as a model
he was just an ordinary guy
who is called upon to do extraordinary
things
under these circumstances so thank you
all very much for coming
you